AND THE NEW MOVIE.
THAT'S "THE STORY" TONIGHT.
TUCKER IS UP.
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER
CARLSON TONIGHT."
THE PRESIDENT LITERALLY THROUGH
OUT THE SCRIPT TODAY.
HE WOUND UP TALKING ABOUT
EMIGRATION INSTEAD.
HERE'S PART OF IT.
>> IT'S A LOTTERY SYSTEM, PICK
THEM OUT.
YOU CAN IMAGINE WHAT THOSE
COUNTRIES PUT INTO THE SYSTEM.
THEY ARE NOT PUTTING THEIR GOOD
ONES.
REMEMBER IN MY OPENING REMARKS
AT TRUMP TOWER WHEN I OPENED,
EVERYBODY SAID "HE WAS SO TOUGH"
I USED THE WORD "RAPE" ."
THEY DON'T WANT TO MENTION THAT.
>> Tucker: OF THAT LINE IS
LEADING NIGHTLY NEWS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY TONIGHT.
HOW DARE HE TIE EMIGRATION TO
RAPE.
ONE CNN CORRESPONDENT PUT IT A
MINUTE AGO.
TRUMP "DOESN'T TIE HIMSELF.
MAYBE YOU SAW HIM ON FOX NEWS
ARE WATCHING ALEX JONES.
HIS HABIT IS TO REPEAT THEM
REGARDLESS OF DISPROVING THEM.
MAYBE TRUMP WAS READING
"THE HUFFINGTON POST" ACTUALLY
BECAUSE JUST A FEW YEARS AGO
BEFORE THEY STARTED LYING FULL
TIME, THE PEOPLE IN CHARGE WERE
SLIGHTLY LESS ANXIOUS TO CHANGE
THE SUBJECT.
HERE IS A VERBATIM
SEPTEMBER 2014 HEADLINE.
"80% OF CENTRAL AMERICAN WOMEN
AND GIRLS ARE RAPE-D
IMMIGRATION AFFECTS PUBLIC
SAFETY AND ANYONE WHO DENIES
THAT STATEMENT ARE DISHONEST AND
A LOT OF PEOPLE DO DENY IT.
THEY DENOUNCE YOU.
DIVERSITY IS OUR STRENGTH AS IF
THAT SETTLES THE CONVERSATION BY
ITSELF.
THEY DON'T WANT TO KNOW THE
DETAILS.
FACTS ARE A THREAT TO THEIR
FANTASIES.
WHATEVER THEY SAY, FACTS DON'T
GO AWAY.
THEY PERSIST DESPITE OFFICIAL
ATTEMPTS TO ERASE THEM AND HERE
ARE SOME FACTS FROM THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
DEMOCRATIC SENATOR KAMALA HARRIS
HAS CALLED HER STATEMENT FUTURE
OF AMERICA AND SHE MAY BE RIGHT.
CALIFORNIA HAS FOR GENERATIONS
BEEN ON THE LEADING EDGE OF
NATIONAL TRENDS IN THIS COUNTRY.
LOOKING AT CALIFORNIA, WHAT DOES
IT TELL US ABOUT OUR FUTURE?
AND CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW, MORE
THAN 6% OF THE ENTIRE STATE IS
THERE ILLEGALLY.
THAT'S ABOUT TWO AND A HALF
MILLION PEOPLE.
HALF OF THOSE HAVE A STATE
DRIVER'S LICENSE.
POLITICIANS IN CALIFORNIA ARE
VERY PROUD OF THAT FACT.
THEY BRAG ABOUT WHAT A GREAT
PLACE CALIFORNIA IS FOR ILLEGAL
ALIENS.
BY THE WAY, THEY'RE RIGHT.
IT IS A GREAT PLACE, IT'S WAY
BETTER.
WHAT IS CALIFORNIA LIKE FOR
EVERYONE ELSE?
44% OF CALIFORNIANS DO NOT SPEAK
ENGLISH AT HOME.
ITS INFRASTRUCTURE IS
COLLAPSING.
THAT IS OUT OF CONTROL, SCHOOLS
ARE UNUSABLE.
PUBLIC SPACES ARE FILTHY.
THE MIDDLE CLASS IS FLEEING
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL THOSE REASONS
APPEAR NORMAL PEOPLE CAN'T LIVE
THERE ANYMORE.
IN 2016, MORE THAN 100,000
CALIFORNIANS LEFT HERE IN
HOUSING PRICES ARE OUT OF
CONTROL, WAGES ARE TOO LOW TO
KEEP UP.
THE STATE INCREASINGLY CONSISTS
OF LOW WAGE SERVICES.
HOW LONG BEFORE ITS VENEZUELA?
YOU'RE NOT SUPPOSED TO THINK
ABOUT ANY OF THAT.
LEADERS COMMAND YOU NOT TO.
WHY WOULD WE SEND SOME TO
PROTECT THE BORDERS?
AS MORNING JOE REMINDED US JUST
TODAY, BORDER CROSSINGS ARE
DOWN, BUT THAT'S A LIE LIKE MUCH
OF WHAT YOU HEAR RIGHT NOW.
IT'S UNTRUE.
LAST MONTH, MORE THAN 50,000
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS WERE CAUGHT
AT OUR BORDER.
THINGS ARE GETTING BETTER, GO TO
CALIFORNIA AND SEE FOR YOURSELF.
AS KAMALA HARRIS SAID, IT'S OUR
FUTURE.
I'M GLAD YOU'RE BACK, YOU'VE
BEEN ON THE SHOW NUMBER OF
TIMES.
YOU MAKE THE CASE, IT'S A PRETTY
COMMON CASE THAT EMIGRATION
INCLUDED MAKES US RICHER.
IF THAT IS TRUE, WHY DOES A
STATE WITH THE HIGHEST NUMBER OF
IMMIGRANTS, LEGAL AND ILLEGAL,
THE HIGHEST PORTION OF
IMMIGRANTS NOW HAVE MORE POVERTY
THAN ANY OTHER STATE AND IT'S
ALMOST A TRILLION DOLLARS IN
DEBT?
WHY ISN'T IT WORKING?
>> IN CALIFORNIA, YOU HAVE AN
ECONOMY THAT'S THE SIXTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD AND I'M NOT
GOING TO SAY THAT CALIFORNIA
DOESN'T HAVE ITS SHARE OF
CHALLENGES, BUT THOSE CHALLENGES
ARE NOT TO BE LAID AT THE SEAT
OF THE COMMUNITY.
QUITE FRANKLY, THEY ARE
PRESENTING CHALLENGES FOR
EVERYBODY, SO THERE'S A LOT OF
POLICY CHANGES THAT CAN BE PUT
INTO PLACE TO HELP EVERYBODY
PROSPER IN CALIFORNIA, BUT --
>> Tucker: I'M NOT BLAMING
ANYBODY.
I'M ACTUALLY ASKING YOU TO
DEFEND THE ARGUMENT THAT YOU
MADE ON THIS SHOW AND THAT MANY
OTHERS LIKE YOU MAKE EVERY DAY
WHICH IS THAT AMERICA BECOMES
MORE PROSPEROUS BECAUSE OF OUR
IMMIGRATION POLICIES.
HERE'S THE STATE THAT HAS MORE
IMMIGRANTS THAN OTHERS AND IT'S
GETTING POORER.
I WOULD LIKE TO ASK YOUR ACCOUNT
FOR YOUR PETITION, IF YOU WOULD.
SPEAK UP WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITY IN
CALIFORNIA, IT'S THE LARGEST
AGRICULTURAL SECTOR AND THE
COUNTRY THAT IS DRIVEN BY AND
LARGE BY THE IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITY.
THE REST OF THE COUNTRY HAS A
HARD TIME --
>> Tucker: THAT'S NOT TRUE.
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE HAS
BECOME INCREASED LATE
MECHANIZED.
I'M FROM THERE.
IT REQUIRES LESS LABOR NOW.
>> WHEN I TALK TO GROWERS IN
CALIFORNIA, THEY'RE LOOKING FOR
LABORERS TO PICK CROPS SUCH AS
STRAWBERRIES, MELONS.
THESE ARE NOT CROPS YOU CAN PICK
WITH MACHINES.
YOU KNOW THAT.
>> Tucker: AGRICULTURE NEEDS
LABOR, NOT DENYING THAT.
>> WHY ARE THERE GROWERS LEAVING
CROPS IN THE GROUND?
>> Tucker: THERE ARE ROBBER
PROBLEMS IN CALIFORNIA.
THERE ARE A LOT OF PROBLEMS IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE TRUTH IS YOU HAVE ARGUED
CONSISTENTLY ON THIS SHOW THAT
LETTING IN MORE PEOPLE FROM
OTHER COUNTRIES WITH LOW
EDUCATION LEVELS MAKE US RICHER.
WE HAVE A CASE STUDY CALLED
CALIFORNIA AND THE OPPOSITE HAS
HAPPENED.
THE ONUS IS ON YOU TO GIVE A
REAL EXPLANATION, NOT TELL ME
THAT AGRICULTURE BRINGS A LOT OF
POOR PEOPLE AND IS NOT TRUE AND
YOU KNOW IT'S NOT TRUE.
>> WHAT HAPPENS IN CALIFORNIA,
THE SIXTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
COUNTRY, YOU HAVE IMMIGRANTS
COMING WORKING ALONGSIDE
AMERICAN WORKERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES, WHETHER IT'S IN THE
TECH SECTOR OR THE AGRICULTURAL
SECTOR.
IN BOTH, IMMIGRANTS ARE HELPING
CREATE JOBS IN CALIFORNIA.
>> Tucker: WHAT I'M DOING --
WHAT I'M ASKING FOR IS AN ADULT
CONVERSATION.
YOU LITERALLY JUST STARED INTO
THE CAMERA LIKE I'M SOME KIND OF
MORON AND SAID THE EGG SECTOR IS
DRIVING IMMIGRATION.
I KNOW THE NUMBERS.
THAT'S NOT EVEN UNTRUE, IT'S
RIDICULOUS.
HERE'S MY OTHER QUESTION.
WHY IS THE MIDDLE-CLASS LEAVING?
WHY ARE 100,000 PEOPLE MOVING TO
OTHER STATES?
>> BECAUSE IN CALIFORNIA, YOU
HAVE A STATE THAT HAS INCREDIBLE
ZONING ISSUES THAT YOU JUST
TALKED ABOUT.
THIS IS NOT A PROBLEM THAT THE
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY LOOKS AT.
THESE ARE THE CHALLENGES THAT
COMES WITH ECONOMIC GROWTH.
>> Tucker: WHY ARE PEOPLE
LEAVING?
I DON'T THINK YOU'RE GOING TO
CONCEDE THAT IMMIGRATION HAS ANY
ROLE IN ANY OF THIS WHICH IS
DISHONEST AND WE BOTH KNOW IT
IS.
LET ME ASK YOU THIS.
IRREFUTABLY, 44% OF CALIFORNIA
HOUSEHOLDS, DOES THAT BOTHER YOU
AT ALL?
DO YOU THINK THAT SUGGESTS
PROBLEMS AHEAD QUESTION RICK A
STATE IN WHICH THERE IS NO
COMMON LANGUAGE.
COULD THAT POSSIBLY CAUSE
PROBLEMS THERE?
>> WHEN YOU TALK TO EDUCATORS
AND FAMILIES ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, YOU SEE THEY ARE
LOOKING TO LEARN ENGLISH BECAUSE
THEY UNDERSTAND THAT IF THEY
LEARN ENGLISH, THEY GET A BETTER
JOB, THEIR CHILDREN HAVE A
BETTER LOT IN LIFE.
THE FACT IS IF THE IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITY AND CALIFORNIA AND
ACROSS THE COUNTRY IS WAITING IN
LINE TO LEARN ENGLISH.
>> Tucker: EVERY YEAR YOU HAVE
A HIGHER PERCENTAGE OF
HOUSEHOLDS IN CALIFORNIA THAT
DON'T SPEAK ENGLISH.
IF WHAT YOU SAID IS TRUE, WHY IS
THAT FACT TRUE?
>> BECAUSE YOU HAVE MORE AND
MORE PEOPLE WHO ARE LOOKING TO
LEARN THE LANGUAGE.
THE ULTIMATE WAY TO BECOME
AMERICAN --
>> Tucker: AND YET MORE AND
MORE WHO DON'T KNOW IT.
MAGIC.
OKAY.
I JUST WANT TO HAVE A FACT-BASED
CONVERSATION.
NOBODY ELSE DOES.
THIS IS REAL.
>> I DIDN'T SAY THAT.
LET'S NOT PUT WORDS IN MY MOUTH.
>> Tucker: I DON'T THINK YOU
SAID THAT AND I DIDN'T MEAN TO
SUGGEST YOU DID.
MANY PEOPLE SAY THAT.